but most of it was around communication
the recruitment mentors podcast is
proudly sponsored
by vincerie who are weaponizing
recruiters
through tech and the award-winning
source breaker who are
transforming the way recruiters work
most of it was around all right so this
is what you got to you know what you got
to do
you know most people in recruitment know
what they've got to do you know you know
what the challenge is right so
so how are you going to communicate with
that team how are you going to do this
and and he was super super helpful in
helping me
frame conversations frame right okay so
how do i how do i say this and he would
make me role play
you know i felt like a rookie again you
know role playing down the phone's room
and
you know and said you know what when i
look back and i remember sort of doing
it for the first time the engagement
that we got and then the
i suppose the the camaraderie and and i
suppose the togetherness we got from
really practicing right what what do i
want people to hear
what do i want to say but what do i want
them to hear is the most important thing
um that was really useful working with
the coach so it was less around
probably me and how do i make my
business better but
right okay so how are you going to help
me specifically communicate these
messages he's not going to do it i've
got to do it
but using that person is a really good
sounding board